enfrentarse al caos de teherán en
bicicleta era algo impensable hace años
para saber más que a los coches tenía la
reacción de los más conservadores que
aún hoy no ven con buenos ojos que una
mujer pedal en lugares públicos
somos nosotras las que ganamos nuestras
libertades y peleamos por ellas
confrontamos los riesgos y los peligros
ácaros
si frente a la ley las mujeres todavía
tienen muchas batallas pendientes en el
campo de lo social son quienes lideran
los cambios con la tradición de tener
mujeres poderosas e independientes
siempre estado presente en la sociedad
iraní para mi reina sofía & max a majid
y es una de las arquitectas más
reconocidas de irán
años atrás apostó por abrir un hotel
boutique que ha liderado la
transformación de la hostelería en
teherán
whitman en shutter y es ver el futuro de
la mujer en irán es brillante por las
mujeres de clase media porque son las
que son ambiciosas porque son ellas las
que están educando hijas poderosas
beijing a ver fútbol muchas de estas
mujeres tienen que enfrentarse a la
oposición de sus familias que muchas
ocasiones tienen reglas aún más
estrictas que aquellas que imponen la
república islámica activistas como
faezeh rafsanjaní reconocen que la lucha
de la mujer se convirtió en un asunto de
seguridad nacional y que esas mujeres no
esperan que el gobierno les dé el visto
bueno ellas mismas siguen adelante en
algunos puntos han sido exitosas y en
otros no el sistema patriarcal se ve
amenazado por la presión de las mujeres
que toman el control de su vida
como respuesta decenas de activistas han
sido detenidas y acosados en los últimos
años como una mojama dimon
yo perdí mi trabajo yo era supervisora
de ingenierías a pesar de que tengo dos
hijos y un marido hace años que viven
lejos y estoy sola
su lucha podría ser aún más difícil con
la llegada de un gobierno conservador
que no puedo elegir otra vida diferente
a esta estoy obligada a luchar y como
ella muchas otras siguen luchando